on this episode NBA star Mason Plumlee
stops by
[Music]
[Music]
you ask a question
[Music]
this is
garyvee everybody for gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is so 251 of the askgaryvee
show pretty excited about this because
I'm a huge NBA fan and we have a
real-life NBA player here with us Mason
Plumlee is here I'm going to give him a
second to tell everybody about himself
but you are so are noticing no phone
today we decided to go old-school on the
askgaryvee show
i put on a tweet we got some questions
and EK it's your chance to finally be
india i'm happy for you there's
something you've wanted for three or
four years i've seen the notes back and
forth you know d-roc show me attacks a
couple years ago said something like
what the [ __ ] why does any always get to
do this so there's a big moment for you
as well my friends i'm happy for you
you're welcome alright Mason why don't
you tell the vaynernation a little bit
about yourself yeah um you know
obviously I play basketball from Indiana
originally with the high school and
college in North Carolina spent my first
two years with the Brooklyn Nets two
years year and a half of the Portland
Trailblazers and then I was traded to
Denver February this season so you know
I'm going into restricted for agency
this offseason so I'm looking forward to
that and you know basketball is my
passion it's what I do is what I gets it
gets me out of bed in the morning I
don't have to think about it I just love
it and I wouldn't trade it for anything
so that's that's my story and that's how
I'm here it's a couple things tell me
about so first of all having being able
to do what you love is like the greatest
right what outside of the basketball
like when we start going into the Mason
sphere of interest that's out of that
Entrepreneurship sci-fi food they would
talk give me some context here and the
viewers at home two things that I've
really been drawn to one being real
estate I've enjoyed a different real
estate projects that I've done with
partners did a couple here in Jersey
when I lived in Jersey and then some in
Washington State when I live
organ but um so real estate has been
very interesting to me gilligan awesome
business model figured out right I play
in a new market buy up right you like
want to get traded and do stuff in free
agency just to build your real estate
empire honestly I was you always want to
be the player like Kobe that's one one
franchise your holes but if it doesn't
happen why not take advantage of pretty
cool so real estate has been interesting
to you and truthful right I'm think
about your career and how long you've
been the league the real estate mark has
been really strong during those years
yeah for sure in the and so when you buy
things and rent out I've done rehab
projects I've done I've invested in
other people's projects but then also
just starting to explore development
with a partner that I have so to me it's
I've always wanted to take advantage of
like I have a window where I know I have
contracts and money coming in but MBA
you can't play for until you're 60 you
can place it to your you know right so
there's a finite time to a career and I
want to take advantage of the earnings
that I have during this time and put
aside some assets for when I retire and
not just earnings right like I mean here
we are sitting obviously we got
connected through you know the inner
readings of our organization but you're
obviously thinking about you know look
40 million people email this place like
I want to be on the show obviously not
only the dollars and where you can
deploy but having the platform of the
MBA itself that gives you opportunities
how are you thinking about the leverage
of just the awareness and a brand or
people willing to say yes the thing is
while you're in a league I think one of
things that I always tell players I
started a sports agency we're starting
to rep players my brother AJ is running
it because it were actually plays a big
day when they have one of our first
players ever gets wrapped 'add I tell
them look I remember this vividly I told
a kid right to his face I go look the
only reason I'm sitting with you is
because your New York jet and the Jets
are my like heart and soul I'm like if
you're a Bronco tomorrow I'm gonna lose
your number and I and I actually meant
it not like to razz him because I was
telling him exacting like a dope and he
wasn't taking advantage of all the
things he could be taking advantage of
you also you know it's funny you said
North Carolina I played you know when
you went to Duke right like some one of
the most popular cut like colleges in
the world like there's just hundreds and
thousands of
people that are ruling the world that
are willing to meet with you because you
went to that university the access is
insane
yeah in I had great veterans when I came
in as a rookie in the league and Kevin
Garnett told me he's like like you can
like you can pretty much sit down or
meet whoever you want to he said you
just have to take the initiative to
reach out to them and they'll take your
call or whatever you want to do they'll
at least listen to you did he then punch
you in the face cuz that's a good thing
he seems like that kind of character no
yeah but you know but but he was writing
in to that point too he also made the
point that he's like once you're done
playing he's like a prayer and picking
up he's like you might not get to sit
down you might not get the return call
whatever but he was like don't wait
until you're 40 he was I mean he was
playing me when he was 38 years old but
because I don't wait til you're 40 to
pick up the phone to you know take
advantage of the platform that you have
you know it's funny you just said that
one of the things that would be
interesting is to think about not only
the real estate arbitrage when you're
new markets but the social graph right
so like like it's kind of interesting
like right like who are the five to 25
men and women that you want to meet when
you're in Portland like literally when
you get to traded to Denver like is one
of the processes and this is where all
the aspiring athletes oh there were
actual athletes you know okay now man
Denver like literally who are the 15 to
25 business or cultural leaders of
Denver that I want to meet and you pull
it off yeah it's interesting
okay how was Duke it was great man I
enjoyed it I stayed all four years you
guys don't do that in
I enjoy it enough to stay like a unicorn
I know um but no it was a lot of fun I
had a great experience that fan base is
ridiculous right so the best most what
about when they're pissed at you yeah I
mean whenever kissing you where they top
or they kind of like fully bought and
they've won so much and you guys have
such like a winning I would think that
winning organizations are soft really
yeah you know like when you're winning
often like they could only get like when
I get mad at a jet player I hate them
with all my heart because we have a one
ever and so like I'm really [ __ ]
pissed at you dude like I want to win
where is it like what the Yankees when I
want a bunch of my fam mad at you but
like we've won like so many
championships like no big deal bro yeah
well you know they had a rough stretch
before I got to school and then the
group I was with my freshman year we won
the championship so it was good it was
good
started off on the right place guys for
years you're trying to get back to that
and it never happened so you know you
have to enjoy the moment take it for
what it is because it's not guaranteed
to happen again you go there one time in
your freshman year you're like oh this
is just what happens knowing a lot you
know knowing a lot of my fan base is a
mix I think some of may not know a lot
about you tell them a little bit about
the family dynamics that I think are
really intriguing with you yeah so I
have two brothers who playing the NBA as
well add a little brother with the New
York Knicks and that older brother with
the Charlotte Hornets we all have one
one year together in high school one
year together in college but I'm those
are my best friends I think I've always
benefited from watching my older brother
go through the same process that I'm
about to embark on and then I've been
able to help my little brother too so
it's been a great dynamic for me and
then also I have a little sister who she
plays volleyball at Notre Dame and now
I'm just like a cheerleader because I
don't know anything about volleyball but
I'm happy are your parents like the
greatest athletes of all time no they
were athletes they weren't the greatest
but they
they would tell you that too but you
know if we grow crazy to think like
forget about even having the DNA the
parenting the serendipity the great
fortune kept three boys in the NBA is so
mind-bending yeah I mean it's not you
see a lot of brothers a lot of twins but
we're happy when Marshall joined the NBA
family yeah this the three the three
thing how often has that happened three
brothers a long time which was I think
is the Barry's right and their dad Lee
right right yeah so that's just insane
doesn't happen do you guys think like
you'll eventually like go on the road
like when you're retired and like you'll
be all about like there's something
really there ya know yeah we could
definitely do something fun we we've
always talked about you I think that the
best part about it has been in our
offseason together and working out
together so I have my little brothers
here like I said with the ax and my
little my little brother likes New York
- so you guys are setting up camp here
this yeah yeah who's the best planner me
know we all say that so but what's the
true answer it is right like it's like
I'll tell you the truth yeah I believe
you all right Andy let's do this in your
big moment what's the OP what's the
first question
Jason Crocker asks do dropped 40 points
on me in high school how early did you
decide to go all-in on basketball and
commit your life to that pursuit well
now I have a new career high in high
school for you do you know what your
career high in high school of course you
do
I really honestly I really don't you
know that good was my career I was like
17 of like said I would know everything
I'm like yeah this kid I crossed him
over no lie I have to give a shout-out
to cry school I love my high school boys
boarding school in North Carolina but we
had such a good group of guy like our
whole our first five all when we played
in college so it was such a fun team to
be on that our whole our goal every year
is like can we don't want to feed it we
really thought we never got to vote you
are one of those guys that came up in
high school where you wore the guy
dropping 64 right so I don't you know
that's that's when the answer but I
didn't have 40 in a game but anyway
might you know for me as a passion early
in indiana's the game everybody plays
basketball and or it's religion yeah it
is it really is like Texas are you cold
fan I am yeah Colts not a Pacers fan but
cold Stan but growing out like oh why
not be first and you know what when I
was when I first started watching the
NBA like it was always Utah and Chicago
in the finals I love Chicago I watched
Jordan all the time so you're a
bandwagon bull fan yeah how's Northwest
Indiana though so I was close to Chicago
that's how you decided to justify that
American I know what they really all
right so what did you so was it for
birth you were all in no I mean when I
was young and just playing at recess on
the playground with my brothers were you
always ridiculously tall no I wasn't
always tall and I think that's the you
know in the NBA not the NBA but in
basketball like you get the guys who are
tall so they're like well I'll play
basketball put this to use but it was
always a passion line from when I was a
little and it's not something I decided
to do because of I ended up being tall
so so when did you go all in all in
honestly to me the first the person I
would say Business Loop concerning
basketball was when I decided to leave
my home and go to a boarding school
because up until then you know I I loved
it I would you go and play for the fun
of it and when was that I did that my
sophomore year high school a big
freshman year I didn't have a big
freshman year I played varsity and JV in
my hometown high school did you throw in
that summer like a machine no I was like
six seven six eight my freshman year so
it just read out I love the kid he's
like nothing you know it's your own
reality right he just hangs out with
7-footers all day I get it but to me
that was going all in because I didn't
it was basketball was for fun and that
was the first sacrifice made toward the
career so Ottawa hoops asked how can
student athletes use social media to
monetize their brain I'll jump in on
this one so so I think I think the NCAA
is ridiculously difficult to navigate
and I have real venneman towards it and
I don't know every detail
I've real venom towards it because I
also grew up in the wine business where
the laws are redic
list and not practical and our archaic
and then it gets even worse when you
really look under the underbelly of why
the rules sit there so I think student
athletes have to be careful because they
can use eligibility right like were you
always scared
like that like it was always like a bad
cloud right and Coach K was like don't
[ __ ] up right no you don't you don't
want to mess up this program he's not
going to like that
but that's the thing the regulation is
the rules you don't you almost you
shouldn't be trying to monetize your
social media because they're going to
hit you over the head with this that's
why I have an answer what your job to do
is to really build if you care about
that if you're that entrepreneurial and
if you're in your javelin you know in
your in volleyball
there's no women's professional
volleyball league that's going to pay
your sister the kind of money the boys
made so if she's thinking about the
entrepreneurial level what you do all
you've got that attention or if you're
the 11th guy at Indiana State and you
don't think you're going to the NBA what
I think when you have that attention is
you build a fan base you don't monetize
it you build the platform the way to do
that whether you're a superstar player
or the 11th guy in Indiana State is to
engage now if you're a superstar player
you're and you're gonna Duke you're
probably worried about your class you're
worried about the program so you
probably have less time if you're 11th
guy at Indiana State you probably have
more time and so you've got to just pull
levers but it's about engagement again
either I'm a hot on this because I just
couldn't Larry Bird reference of you I
didn't want to use Indiana like I've
just thought it was funny so if you're
Indiana State 11th guy right every
single person that references your game
on Twitter is something you can engage
with maybe you didn't play but it would
be really funny if Tyler's like you guys
suck tonight and you jump in or like yo
bro they be pumped because they actually
watched that game that context building
now of sudden you leave school with
80,000 followers where you would have
had maybe 1500 if you didn't give a crap
and now all of a sudden you are tweeting
out looking for opportunities this
summer that's where you're at your
height because you just went through the
program and six or seven leads come in
and the way you go that's really the
only way within the rules of the
n-c-double-a agreed run Rodney Rodney
Peete
you know mommy Peters just yes or no do
you know Marathi Peters Rodney Peete
Rodney Peete Rodney Peete Rodney Peete
Rodney Peete Rodney Peete sorry Ronnie
USC quarterback once of the Lions had a
nice career um these youngsters don't
wanna ride a snow the line he's offering
right here you're a big disappointment
in but through love
Rodney X what did the NBA teach you
about basketball that you can apply to
marketing or branding on social media so
the first thing they do is they sit you
down and show you what you can get fine
for surprisingly a lot of the stuff is I
was watching what guys got in trouble
for all that stuff created such buzz and
got him a lot you like the arbitrage was
worth it yeah yeah yeah to me the best
advices they gave us was be yourself
don't make every post about a product
pitch or you know you right away so you
get as soon as you come out of the
league or as soon as you as soon as you
finish University then you can accept
money for like then you can take your
monetizing right so right away you're
going to have people hate tweet this
pitch my product whatever I'll pay you
for the cards yes it's good and well but
you don't want your social media to be
flooded with that you just want to be
genuine be who you are I think it's also
good share you know don't just reply to
tweets and whatever after wins you know
be the same person wins and losses don't
go into a whole you know depending on
the situation so careful who you were
bonding to Atlantic yeah um always you
know respond to real people I think
there are a lot a lot of people hiding
behind different accounts out there
stuff like that yeah dunk so uh kidding
I'm kidding
tell me talk to me about talk to me
about the biggest thing you learned in
your first season the NBA nothing to do
with marketing just macro learning you
know this has probably been on your mind
you know as a little kid then definitely
got more suiting you're serious after
freshman year of high school here it is
is it you're in the league
what's the biggest thing you learned in
year one Kevin obviously sat down and
gave you some good advice you have some
good bets on
team that you stumbled into but like
what like macro like to me the the
biggest thing I took away is there's so
much like I came from a college where
there's stability Coach K was my coach
every year I have for the most part
similar teammates every year the NBA and
you know I talked to my friends with
other jobs there's so much turnover
there's so much unpredictability like I
went into work I went into practice one
morning and they said hey Jane wants to
talk to you hey you're going to Denver
okay cool
so you can't control your situation you
can you know you do that a d-roc you've
been traded in Chattanooga but it's
crazy
right like if it took up your whole life
yeah there's a lot of great things that
comes along with professional sports and
I'm sure the veterans tell you once your
family kicks in right right
your daughter loves her school in Denver
and now you're in Sacramento yeah so I
think the best piece of advice that I
got from those guys when I watch that
happen on that first team is you know no
matter what's happening around the game
have the same work habits have the same
approach to practice to the games to
shoot around to throw and such have an
approach that you believe in that you
can stick to and every we're not going
to change regardless away and have you
done that yeah I have I mean really four
years in but I but you know on three
teams of four years teams of four years
four different head coaches so I I feel
like I have found a routine something
that I believe in that I can continue to
grow and get better regardless of was it
easier to walk into the Denver locker
room after experience being the new guy
in the Portland locker room yeah for
sure was that weird and scary
um I mean everything everything I would
say unpredictable you don't know what to
expect um I was told well actually funny
when I went into the Denver locker and
they started playing a rap song some
I did a rap song so everywhere I go
people make fun of me for it which is
it's fine I have I have fun with it so
you know that that light in the moon but
anyway like and also the NDA you know
you know players on every team so if you
want to use in high school in college
things of that nature
right right cool and ek Cody wheat asks
what do you think people get wrong about
professional athletes what do you think
is the biggest misconception I can tell
you the thing that bothers me the most
when people talk about athletes are
stupid or dumb or whatever and they go
broke because they don't know what
they're doing I see
I don't know anybody all the players
that I know are still in the league but
they don't people have gone broke or
they've lost you know what they made out
of I've seen more I could see it
happening more from generosity it's
exactly a business it's not I'm so glad
you said this I apologize to cutting you
off I am stunned by that variable as we
just recruited our first class you're
exactly right it's not that they're dumb
it's that one of these their inner
circle and and listen there's a lot of
cliche lower middle class or you know
and it's like they want to help they've
been they've been praying to get through
the system to this moment you know being
rich you can get injured you know coming
from tough places you could get into
trouble like I think that's exactly
right my man they're they're trying to
do good so much so I don't know if
you've seen this I've already seen this
some of these kids have to go through
the very difficult decision of actually
cutting off their world because
literally all that's happening is
there's I saw a kid with a cell phone
and in 30 minutes get asked for tens of
thousands of dollars from 11 different
people it happens all the time and it's
not a really good one that you went that
man who are so quick to say that you
know bad business with a bad restaurant
bad this bad it it I see more the most
generous people I've ever met have been
teammates and NBA at without a doubt now
there's also Antoine Walker who was out
of his mind
yeah I mean and so I know I love and by
the way on that note I'm making that
joke because I want to give him a
compliment what he's doing right now for
kids and like that are coming out of the
league and you know it takes a lot of
humility and listen I'm sure
economics with it I don't know um but
you know he's getting paid and isn't
hurting to get you know doesn't hurt to
get the money but he's going in there
saying look at me they're like look what
happened they made hundreds of millions
of dollars
poof and ek and II felt that one
Sam asks how are you able to stay
positive when working towards your goals
and ambitions without seeing improvement
on a regular basis that to me that's one
of the hardest things you know I think
whether you do part of your game was
toughest for you if you said at a macro
the thing that was hardest for you to
develop in your game yeah that you can
rewind to now like we're going very
macro basketball right now what would
that be like is it like so les last
summer I wanted to change the way in
which I shot the ball platform
period period yeah that's like it's a
little crazy yeah and I was it it's
crazy hard core we have something I
always felt like this Tiger Woods broke
down a swing that had one master and
then he reworked it I wasn't breaking
down I'll break it up I love it I wanted
to change it you know it was very
there's a lot of times I didn't see
progress I didn't you know I got with
the coach and we're in the gym every day
and and it was frustrating stuff felt
awkward it didn't you have muscle memory
and habits that are hard to break it you
the two of them wrong for so long so
that was something that that I you know
I just fully committed to last summer in
and they're like you'd like the question
said there are a lot of times where you
but where are we right now you know I
felt I feel very Dom still 10x so in it
I'm still on that journey I'm very happy
with where my form is you know I hit
more jump shots this year than I have
any year in the league and that's not I
feel like I have a base in a form that I
can build a look on continue to improve
Andy you should know your jump shot is
been struggling lately where are you
right now with your game I mean either
dunk how you feel about yourself you're
very athletic also good we have a
blindly yeah it has the actuality of it
you playing well sir Jake Jake how you
doing
and they if we go up against make yeah
I'll give you a preview you're gonna
lose oh yeah tell me like I said I found
a shooting coaches Yoda's the name of a
dude who's up shooting coach Oh cuz you
have to do all sorts of weird stuff like
close your eyes and like shoot backwards
like while you're elevated Nigella likes
more he's like a bald little girl you
know how you get the gray hair going
around ray almost yeah so he doesn't he
didn't have like they're shooting
coaches in the NBA
of course this guy had no NBA but he's
an unofficial kind of letter old one
will but I watched him and the guy who
made like I think fifteen hundred three
free throws in a row so I was like hey I
want work you saw that I saw that on
YouTube or you were like sitting there
tying your shoes and watched an old
white dude hit fifteen hundred and three
free throws
just curious yeah but so mother got it
yeah you get on on the spot if you log
in the gym he'll rip you off 100 in the
room and I was like that's impossible
you know we call him the other because
he's a little on balding what yeah yeah
I love it good to make some glad you
stopped by man thanks for having me you
get to ask the question of the day you
get to ask any question you want
macro micro basketball life
entrepreneurship interest anything you
want you'll get thousands of answers it
might be some good insight far away
anything anything
oh man what's what's the what's the best
thing to do in New York over the summer
that people don't know about and don't
tell me Hamilton because you can't get
tickets to that
well I can't you get figgus cuz they pay
well in the NBA they do right so buy
some [ __ ] ticket alright figures okay
that's it what's the thing that doing
New York in the summer that that people
don't know about that you just have to
do how about that love it oh man I just
have a buyer you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them
you
[Music]